कि शत्रुओं का मुकाबला करने के सिवाय
शौर्यपूर्ण कार्यों के लिए शौर्य चक्र
को लेफ्टिनेंट कर्नल कृष्ण सिंह रावत सेना
मीटिंग हॉस्पिटल इन दो पैराशूट रेजिमेंट
स्पेशल फोर्स लेफ्टिनेंट कर्नल कृष्ण सिंह
रावत सेना मेडल जम्मू एवं कश्मीर में
नियंत्रण रेखा के निकट आतंकवादी एवं खुश
पैक विरोधी अभियान के तहत एक मिशन के तीन
मीटर के पद पर तैनात 24 दिसंबर 2019 को
उन्हें आतंकवादियों के घुसपैठ करने तथा
उनकी सैन्य टुकड़ी पर घातक हमला कर
जान-माल का नुकसान पहुंचाने के संभावित
प्रयासों की गुप्त सूचना मिली थी
की त्वरित कार्यवाही करते हुए उन्होंने
अपनी टुकड़ी को घुसपैठ के संभावित रास्तों
पर तैनात किया विपरीत मौसम में नियंत्रण
रेखा के समीप लगातार 36 घंटे तक खात लगाने
के बाद उनकी टीम को आतंकवादी समूह की हरकत
का अंदाजा हुआ भीषण गोलीबारी के बीच रहते
हुए यह जांबाज़ अधिकारी आतंकवादियों के
नजदीक पहुंचे और अपने सटीक फाइनल से दो
आतंकवादियों को मार गिराया दोनों ओर से हो
रही अंधाधुंध फायरिंग के बावजूद उन्होंने
अपने दल का उत्कृष्ट मार्ग दर्शन किया एवं
इलाके की लगातार निगरानी करते हुए एक और
आतंकवादी को गंभीर रूप से घायल कर दिया
लेफ्टिनेंट कर्नल कृष्ण सिंह रावत सेना
मेडल में इस पूरे ऑपरेशन के दौरान अदम्य
साहस उत्कृष्ट युद्ध कौशल एवं अनुकरणीय
नेतृत्व क्षमता का परिचय दिया लेफ्टिनेंट
कर्नल कृष्ण सिंह रावत सेना मेडल हुआ है
हुआ है